révolutionnaire provocant et visionnaire
le génie musical de frank zappa est
indéniable le documentaire zappa
contient des archives inédites puisés à
même les voûtes du regretté compositeur
frank zappa est mort en 1940 et
rapidement cet autodidacte s'est imposé
sur la scène musicale des années 1960
s'attirant les éloges de des beach boys
et des rolling stones ce travailleur
infatigable le compositeur réalisera
soixante deux albums en carrière dont
autres at every night sensations et
joe's garage
il enregistrera même avec le maestro
kent nagano et amérique center le
réalisateur alex wynter un fan fini du
musicien avait la lourde tâche de faire
des choix déchirants pour rendre justice
à l'oeuvre
moi j'ai vraiment aimé parce que c'est
comme quelqu'un j'ai connu dans les
derniers milles pige que j'ai connu dans
ma tête aussi
louise lecavalier a dansé en 1992 lors
de la dernière présence sur scène de
frank zappa
on la voit brièvement dans le
documentaire ce qui lui rappelle de
précieux souvenirs
donc quand même déjà très malade sa
santé s'est donné une espèce d'aura
jusqu'à presque quelqu'un qui torchent
qu'à la fin qui sourit aux sages et
reconnue dans le film à la fin quand on
voit sourire on travaille avec
l'ensemble de musique moderne et sourit
ce nu j'ai eu droit se rangera pas est
décédé à l'âge de 52 ans d'un cancer de
la prostate
le film n'a pas montre l'image d'un
musicien sans compromis toute sa vie
partagée entre le rock le jazz et le
classique
j'aime d'un amour inconditionnel frank
zappa
donc j'essaye critique mission envers
tout ce qui touche par exemple donc le
film m'a laissé un peu sur ma faim
j'aurais aimé plus d'image darchy sauf
que parfois on tourne les coins ronds
louise lecavalier soit peu votre avis
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses sur lui
même si au fond j'ai l'impression que je
connaissais déjà des choses mais là ça
s'est concrétisé a envoyé en pleine
séquence mais je sais que faire un film
documentaire c'est extrêmement difficile
de satisfaire beaucoup de gens avec ça
naby alexandre moi je crée c'est surtout
de l'eau plutôt que de rejuger ça m'a
permis de découvrir l'influencé qu'avait
eue sur tant de gens un homme aussi
passionné complètement orientée sur sa
musique
par contre j'ai trouvé des fois on
enchaînait un petit peu des événements
sans vraiment les mettre en contexte
jérémy un peu plus de chair mais c'est
une bonne porte d'entrée pour aller
chercher des informations sur la cité
découvrir le personnage fascinant ici il
est dit alexandre chartier lui fait du
bruit mais radio-canada mourir
[Musique]